how often do you still battle with
depression oh I'm always depressed all
the time do you feel that you're happier
right now than when you're broke or not
really
sometimes I had to stop
because I I had everything and I was
absolutely broken inside I so badly want
to be Catherine Hudson that I don't even
want to look like Katy Perry anymore
sometimes okay
okay I don't want to be too dark but I
genuinely didn't think I would like make
it to like 17. you didn't think you'd
make it to 17. no from the outside it
looks like celebrities have the perfect
life but in reality being an A-list
celebrity absolutely sucks mental
breakdowns addictions depression
bankruptcy and sometimes even death but
why why is having what everyone else
seems to want money and fame always
seems to lead to disaster when you're an
A-list celebrity that everyone knows you
can pretty much say goodbye to going
outside when you're in a coffee shop
everyone recognizes you and it's not
really a pleasant interaction typically
for the celebrity because all they see
is all these people bothering them for a
photo and it's not like these people
genuinely want to take the time to get
to know them and we all know when we see
a celebrity we want to run up to them to
get the photo and so if all you're
experiencing as a celebrity is like all
these people just want to take something
from you which is you just want to take
the photo they just want to sometimes
get your number or whatever it might be
it's not a pleasant experience of
dealing with human beings is Arvid Ali
by the way he's the former president of
Jordan Belfort's companies yes the real
Wolf of Wall Street and he's the advisor
that celebrities pro athletes
politicians and the ultra Rich go-to
when they want to grow their net worth
so he's been very up close and personal
with A-list celebrities at first all
this attention will seem exciting you're
gonna feel validated all these random
people want me but after a while it
starts to wear you down you can't escape
it everywhere you go everyone knows you
and wants something from you every
little thing you do is being scrutinized
in videotapes from the way you eat food
to the way you walk to a time you
spilled food on your shirt you're always
on edge you always have to make sure
you're on your best behavior you're not
allowed to be in a bad mood Robert
Pattinson explained what that's like in
an interview with Premier magazine a
couple years ago and it does not sound
great he said that when he's in Los
Angeles he has about 40 seconds from the
moment he arrives somewhere before
somebody asks for his autograph and you
can bet that every Aaron would turn into
a Photoshop with strangers to your fans
are more like an object than an actual
human being basic respect just goes out
the door one time he had heart
palpitations while on stage and had to
be rushed to the hospital as he's being
carried in on a gurney his nurse asks
him to autograph his electrocardiogram
sheet and then there's the paparazzi
thank you
the Bottom Feeders of the celebrity
world whose job it is to trigger you
got it away I can't see there are cars
there
my children please yeah I'm not doing
your children you might better keep your
hands away from me so what's the
solution you literally just don't stuff
foot outside you spend your days trapped
inside your home alone so naturally they
end up just staying at home all day most
of them they're sitting on social media
watching videos watching Netflix playing
video games let's think about that
humans were not meant to be locked
inside alone in one location all day
every day so naturally as a celebrity
you're gonna get depressed and anxious
90 of the time they're just sitting at
home all day and you know for anybody
well it doesn't really matter who you
are it's very easy to become not only
depressed and have anxiety but just
fundamentally your sense of belonging
really sort of disappears you really
feel quite lonely and you feel as though
the only thing that people care about
when it comes to you is being able to
take a photo with you so that they can
brag to their friends but Jake that may
be the case but come on even though
A-list celebrities have to stay inside
all day they've got to be hanging out
with all the coolest friends right wrong
stay dangerous subscribe for more and
this is why celebrities are always
depressed
[Music]
since we're on the subject of famous
people do you know what Winston
Churchill Leonardo da Vinci and Thomas
Jefferson all have in common they all
use standing dust why because setting
down is actually one of the worst things
ever for you I work from home and I find
that when I'm sitting down too much it
cuts off the circulation in my legs you
get that aggressive arch in your lower
back your shoulders fold forward giving
you an unattractive posture sitting down
is just terrible for you which is why
I've been using standing desk for over
six years now and I've tried a lot of
Brands but when I got my hands on feisty
spots E7 I fell in love the desktop has
pre-drilled holes unlike other brands so
you don't need to drill the next thing I
noticed is that unlike other brands that
have cheap plastic physical buttons
flexi spot has this nice touch pad that
is super quick and responsive but my
favorite part is that the motors are
fast most standing desks move really
slow which is really annoying when
you're adjusting the height all the time
like I do this has been one of my
favorite investments in my health and if
you want to pick one up today is the
best day to get it because flexi spot is
having a Labor Day sale with up to 50
off products so click the link below to
get one now thanks to flexi spot for
sponsoring this video
when you're at the top you naturally
can't trust anyone anymore so say
goodbye to making any new friends you
have all these people around me just
kind of hanging on wanting stuff from me
knowing that like I was living this
lifestyle that they also wanted to live
well what about all their old childhood
friends you ask well those that get to
the top were usually the weird ones
growing up so they probably didn't have
many friends those that get to the top
also have to be pretty neurotic and
obsessive to get there they have to grow
a lot as a person so even if they did
have any old friends you can bet that
they probably outgrew them they have
like a friend here they're you know that
you have some sort it's usually
something related family or family
friend that they've known but in terms
of like friends you know where you hang
out with your friends I would say like
probably 99 of them have zero actual
friends that they hang out with
regularly but come on the male
celebrities have got to be banged all
the hottest fan girls rights well it's
complicated you have to think about it
from their perspective like every single
girl that you get with as a male
celebrity is a risk there's a
significant risk that they're gonna try
to take a picture with you they're going
to try to use it against you somehow and
and they want you ideally to become you
know their romantic partner so they'll
do whatever oftentimes they'll do
whatever it takes to try to cause
problems so that you can become a
romantic partner of theirs but what
about the exclusive celebrity parties
you ask the ones with all those hot
Instagram models another thing that's
typically associated with celebrities is
like they get to go to all these
exclusive influencers celebrity parties
and from my understanding you've been to
someone
I've been to quite a lot of them um
and uh it's probably probably the
saddest part he's ever been to um it
looks really glamorous it's amazing from
the outside the houses are just
unbelievable and lying and they have
like thousands of models and stuff and
it's a very dramatic situation but
inside the party if you think about it
okay so let's say you have like 2 000
Instagram models and you have like 50
male you know top celebrities it sounds
like something crazy is going on but
practically inside the party what you
have is a bunch of Instagram models who
are worried to be be photographed doing
anything you know wrong basically and
you definitely have all those guys who
are very worried to be put around doing
anything wrong and so everyone's just
standing around doing nothing and it's
like almost intolerable to me because
everyone's just sitting and standing by
themselves with these like unbelievably
famous people they're just standing
around they're not doing anything maybe
they're slightly mingling and then I'm
like the only person who's just
basically you know really trying to pump
up the environment and dancing by myself
to get people excited but uh yeah I I I
uh stop going for a good reason it's not
a fun thing to do I do think that there
are some more wild parties that you hear
about when it comes to some of the tech
billionaire guys but in terms of actual
celebrities it's very rare but yeah
that's as much as I can go into it right
now so when you become an Ayla celebrity
the only time you're ever going to be
leaving your house is to go to work the
only time they tend to leave their house
I would say is if they have to so for
certain musicians artists they have to
go on tour which if you guys have ever
really seen their videos of going on
towards incredibly difficult experience
where they can barely sleep they have to
go to multiple locations within 24 hours
and it's for many months non-stop it's
absolutely not pleasant at all for
anyone who has to go through that
despite the controversies Beaver
launched his purpose World Tour in 2017.
150 concerts across 40 countries in 16
months
but what fans saw a visibly exhausted
pop star on stage
Bieber abruptly cancels the Final 14
shows posting on Instagram me taking
this time right now is me saying I want
to be sustainable I want my career to be
sustainable but I also want my mind
heart and soul to be sustainable but
come on think about all the money Jake
Cillian Murphy Just Got Paid 10 million
dollars for Oppenheimer alone that movie
sucked by the way I will take tens of
millions of dollars if it means I just
have to stay home and have no friends
well think again
foreign
[Music]
go hand in hand but that's far from the
truth in fact most celebrities quickly
end up broke think about it they get one
payday and then it's gone most of the
time their income streams are very
short-lived so that maybe they have a
movie that does well or they have one
album but it's a very stressful
situation because if you've just
suddenly made a large sum of income in
one short time frame what happens after
that short time frame now you're like
sitting around and you don't have new
income coming in oftentimes they become
very financially stressed I've never
found a celebrity who's not extremely
stressed about their income even the
ones that are multi-billionaires or
whatever but it's not just the
unpredictable paydays it's that in
between the unpredictable paydays comes
a lot of unexpected expenses That
Celebrity will make like 10 million
dollars in one year but then the next
year their income could go to like
literally zero is that correct and it's
not just zero it's actually quite in the
negative because you know maybe they
make the 10 million and then during that
time their basic expenses go up so even
if let's imagine you're you're not
trying to live any sort of lavish
lifestyle very commonly you know you'll
want to take care of your closest family
members like your parents or your
siblings or some of your close friends
and then your basic minimum expenditure
each month even if you're not living
lavishly at all and oftentimes you'll
find with a lot of celebrities they
really don't but their expenses and even
whether it's on the paying lawyers
paying paying their accountants paying
their investors whatever it might be
their basic expenses goes up so much
during those times when they do make
money but the second they stop making
money
um they're dramatically in the negative
Britney Spears paid 17 000 per month
just to transport her safely from place
to place Johnny Depp spends 150 000 per
month on security for his children and
he pays another three hundred thousand
dollars to pay for his 40 plus other
staff members he has multiple million
dollars in debts and then there's the
lawsuits ah yes when you're well known
and people think you have money the
pathetic maggots are gonna come trying
to sue you for every stupid little
reason they can think of and even if
they have more than enough money to
cover all of this they never feel
financially secure even the ones that
are worth hundreds of millions of
dollars or billions of dollars
practically speaking because they
usually didn't grow up like you know
Ultra Rich they're always thinking about
you know what's their actual income it's
not this glamorous situation I've never
found a celebrity who's not extremely
stressed about their income even the
ones that are multi-billionaires or
whatever if you're in their shoes it's
very hard to break from that habit of
stressing about your income and that
applies to everyone not just not just
celebrities I've never found someone no
matter how much money that they have
that genuinely feels like they're
financially comfortable and safe and
that might just be you know sort of a
western United States thing that's
that's another unfortunate reality
they're not living some sort of
Lifestyle where they're really happy and
they feel like they're super rich and
famous it's more like I'm stressed out
about my finances and I can't trust
anybody and so what do I do functionally
the only answer is I'll just sit here at
home alone so how do celebrities cope
with all the Solitude all this pressure
drugs usually a lot of drugs there was a
time where I was sipping lean I was
popping pills I was doing Molly
um you know shrooms everything and it
was just an escape for me the reality of
situations is you can't as a world
expect to break people down constantly
and not expect them to want some type of
Escape I I don't have a mom I can call I
don't have a father I can call I don't
have my you know what I'm saying like my
like my aunt was the last thing that I
had is gone when you're a celebrity you
can get access to whatever substances
you want which leads to really tragic
outcomes we're going to turn now to a
major loss in the music world tonight
the gifted singer Amy Winehouse found
dead in her London home she was just 27
and so many people blogging and tweeting
throughout the day today about an almost
Eerie coincidence so many young music
Stars lost and so many lost the actor
Heath Ledger was found dead today in an
apartment here in New York City he was
just 28 years old the australian-born
actor came to huge from dominance after
his powerful performance and the film
Brokeback Mountain 6 30 they loaded the
body of Michael Jackson onto that
helicopter and in just a couple of
minutes they're making their Final
Approach now to County USC Medical
Center in the Skies over Los Angeles
news crews tracked the helicopter
carrying Michael Jackson's body in death
the King of Pop just as much a figure of
Fascination as he was in life and here's
the other irony is that the famous not
gonna last forever and when it's over
things usually get worse not better
[Music]
from the ones that make it out alive
Fame Is Not Gonna Last Forever one day
you will turn into a husband for some
they stay relevant for a super long time
for others their famous short-lived the
other big thing is most people who are
super famous they don't stay in the
spotlight for that long so everyone
might know them for many decades later
but like your time and your Prime is
kind of limited and when it's all over
even though the fame might have been
miserable they tied their entire
identity around this it validated them
they tied their entire self-worth around
it so when they do become a husband they
become even more depressed what does a
32 year old retiree who's worth 100
million dollars spend their days
miserable really you're miserable yeah
because you know like any athlete right
from the ages of six seven years old all
we knew was one thing hoop hoop school
right who's summer who play what do we
know when we haven't had a regular life
no matter how much money you have if you
don't have it that's why when you when
you hear someone they're like yeah my
parents still work usually they go
searching for the same rush they once
had some of them find a healthy Outlets
but many don'ts let me answer why do I
DJ from 13 to 40 three times a week for
an hour and a half I would get
adrenaline from people yelling the
screen the good yelling bad yelling
cheering booing it's just a part of me
when I stopped playing I didn't have
that I get doses of it I could go on the
rest like I go on Nick and sand and I
get a little clap but it's only 30
seconds like where's the rest so I went
to a concert one time and it was about
half a million people that went to
Tomorrowland in Atlanta and that feeling
came back yeah and I've been DJing since
high school since college and I was like
I think I can do this because the
concept of the DJ and the athlete should
be the same this is my concept when a
person pays money to see you perform
give them a good show okay okay okay
being a celebrity is not all it's
cracked out to be I see that now Jake so
I'll just become a billionaire instead
I'll have all the money in the world
with none of the fame there well not so
fast
thank you
[Music]
money without the fame it sounds like a
dream come true but in reality
billionaires all deal with their own set
of insecurities that gnaw at their soul
you have a situation where this person
is extremely rich you know let's say
um at least on paper or whatever it
might be and then they get and then they
see all these random other dudes
especially on the internet who are
really famous who aren't nearly as rich
and so then they're super jealous and
annoyed at all these not you know sort
of fake Rich guys out there who get all
the fame and the attention and so you
have all these sort of billionaires who
are typically sad that no one knows who
they are it's not like you can walk
around the street if you're not a famous
you know billionaire as well you can
walk around the street and people like
you know bow down to you as if they know
who you are and they wish they could get
some respect from people because they uh
there there's some sort of like a big
time silent success think about it what
if this guy walked past you on the
streets would you recognize him of
course not he looks like another generic
old dude are you gonna run up to him and
say how much of a big fan you are of him
while he's out on a date with a girl
he's trying to impress no but you want
to know who this man is that's amancio
Ortega The Man Behind Zara with a net
worth of 90 billion dollars and here's
the thing even if these billionaires
wanted to get famous they literally
can't it's a it's a big negative for
them to be well known
um for many different reasons oftentimes
it has to do with how they actually
became a billionaire but
um definitely you know if they become
well-known billionaire then they're just
going to get sued all day every day by
random people
um it's very common for them to have to
spend tens of millions of dollars you
know just protecting themselves from
from all these frivolous lawsuits and
um it's just not a safe thing for for
most billionaires so practically
speaking like the odds that you're going
to want to be well known is as a
billionaire is very low but then at the
same time it's this weird irony where
you wish everybody knew you and
respected you and so um so then you
treat everyone kind of uh poorly for
lack of better term because you wish
they respected you oftentimes but you
know they don't so um so so that's
that's that's what it's like to deal
with billionaires too with just
um famous people
um it has much more to do with like sort
of the coveted loneliness and you almost
kind of just feel sad for them and then
they're stressed out because they're
worried about their income and the
billionaires this other thing the the
one big overlap is both of them are
extremely worried about their income all
the time
um but uh the type of misery is a little
bit different the the celebrity is more
like loneliness loneliness misery and
the billionaires it's it's more like uh
a a yearning for respect
um and so so it's not particularly
Pleasant dealing with them at least at
least from my experiences
um yeah obviously they're exceptions you
know for for anyone watching this way
you know still work with
um on uh on the billionaire side but um
uh yeah generally speaking this is the
case so if extreme wealth sucks if
extreme Fame sucks what doesn't suck is
there a way to achieve the money in
theme without making your life miserable
well as it turns out there is a happy
medium you can shoot for
[Music]
I think it's great to be narrowly famous
within a very specific Niche for example
like if you are a YouTuber or if you are
even a singer or whatever it might be if
you have an audience and it's not even a
ideally it's not an insanely large
audience like 10 000 people love you so
to speak online or wherever those are
the people that really have the best
situation where they just get to deal
with their true fans and they you know
they don't really interact with them in
person all that much but like their
online interactions are nice and then in
real life they get to just experience
your life whenever they want to and then
if they really really want to they can
just create some sort of fan specific
experience once a year and and have that
as a very fun thing to do or something
like that but they get to have the best
of both worlds in my opinion which is
like they get to have a normal real life
and not deal with any of the problems
and at the same time they know that
there's that there's thousands of people
out there who do really love them and
and their content and uh there's no real
downside so so I think that's a nice
happy medium but
um you never know like if you're just
good at becoming famous then you're
probably just gonna keep you any more
famous I would say that there are two
routes that I found that work you really
do find some sort of work where you
genuinely enjoy the work regardless of
the income but it is still you know
something that's a profession meaning
you really can't make an income from it
I've generally found that like you know
almost for most professions if you
really do like it it's it is very doable
to at least you know get into six
figures in income let's even say you
love doing uh video editing you know you
can work for one person as a video
editor where you can you know multiply
yourself and work for a few people as a
video editor so there's always a way to
increase your income over time
regardless of what profession you really
like the same thing with software
Engineers same things with with any
profession really you can scale yourself
ideally to get to a point where you can
get six figures that's that's one route
the other route I would say is where if
you really do just care about money if
you can get to a point where your focus
is on having a predictable consistent
income but you don't have to work that
much that's kind of the best route
oftentimes that might be that uh you
create some sort of business and
eventually you you know you hire some
people to to take over the work that
you're doing but you just scale it to a
point where it makes you know however
much money is a lot of money practically
speaking if you are really focused on
just money the better thing to do is is
maybe get seven figures and reduce your
workload so that you can enjoy the seven
figures and the reason why RV was able
to come to this conclusion is because he
literally had to explore all these
different Avenues himself so how do you
realize all this like
um because you're like super
knowledgeable about the celebrity world
and the billionaire world and uh this
world of like scaling up your income so
how did you come to this conclusion I
was mostly obsessed since from a very
young age to just figure out how I can
retire early because I myself was
actually depressed since the age of five
so my obsession was like okay I hate
school I hate I never want to work first
went into Silicon Valley and then I was
like oh this is cool you know all these
young people are getting rich here you
know I can get rich as a young person
and for me it ended up being I created a
consulting firm in Silicon Valley where
I served as a consultant to around 50 to
55 super fast growing startups six of
them ended up becoming worth well over a
billion dollars and I helped a lot of
those companies out at the early stages
and then after doing the consulting firm
I then got into the sort of Hollywood
celebrity world just by accident but it
was but it worked out for me because I
it fulfilled a lot of my requirements I
was like okay this is great I can get
even richer being in this world of
celebrities and I get like these
celebrity name attachments to make my
parents happy with me so it ended up
working out well because there aren't
that many people with the Silicon Valley
background that that went into the
Hollywood space so I had a unique
advantage in going in there and helping
out a lot of celebrities
using all the knowledge that I got from
seeing so many Silicon Valley companies
do so well and then realize exactly you
know what they did right what they did
wrong and be able to bring that into the
Hollywood celebrity business space and
mostly celebrities because they make so
much money they have a lot of different
businesses that they either create or
involved in as an investor and so it was
it was an easy transition actually and
then from there I ended up sort of
thinking like okay this is cool what
else am I missing because at that point
I was just like I kind of want to just
see what other parts of the world or
aspects of the world that I'm missing
and the rest to me was uh was with both
politics and uh with with billionaires
so then I uh became an advisor to those
groups of people more recently and then
after having experienced that then I I
fully kind of came full circle where I
was like okay uh now that I've seen all
that I've ever wanted to see or actually
way more than I ever wanted to or needed
to see what do I like doing and uh
personally the only thing I really feel
extremely fulfilled doing is helping
other people one-on-one I really don't
like you know dealing with large groups
of people or corporations or whatever
anymore I'd much rather just deal with
people one-on-one and be able to help
them in a way where it's not so much
that like I'm creating some sort of
Genius Playbook that everyone should
follow type thing it's more just like a
real genuine 101 help where I've just
seen so much now of what works what
doesn't work and seeing what everyone
else has tried and being able to
translate that into each person's
specific situation so in some cases
that's in that that ends up being more
related to to Growing their income in
other cases it ends up being more in
terms of personal fulfillment and their
relationships but overall I wanted to be
able to take all the work I did with
advising all these types of people and
be able to translate that down into
helping as many individuals as I can and
I didn't want to do it in a way where
it's sort of uh some like Cookie Cutter
you know type thing I really want to
help every individual one by one myself
not like you know have somebody else do
it so uh that's why at this point I'm
trying to help people through one-on-one
calls and I relaunch my my YouTube
channel and I want to share as much as I
can uh and then hopefully people find
Value from it and what I find really
interesting is that you know you've
taken phone calls from Big corporations
for like ten thousand dollars one of our
friends pays you around 10K a month just
for a monthly phone call but you doing
these phone calls with you know people
that reach out to you that watch your
videos you seem way more animated way
more excited about them getting someone
to schedule a call and having a chance
to help these people one-on-one you know
these strangers one-on-one basically is
way more exciting and fulfilling than
than any phone call I've ever done with
any Corporation and it doesn't really
matter you know whether a corporation is
paying me like 10 or 20 000 per phone
call it's not like it doesn't really add
anything exciting you know to your life
Arvid recently put out a video going
over his crazy life story in much more
detail than what we could go over in
this video so if you're interested in
learning more click the card on the
screen to watch his video now and after
you watch the video if you want to talk
one-on-one with them you can book a call
with a link in the description of that
video
[Music]